that's one of the best things to see at
disney oh wow
welcome to the evan carmichael show
good morning we're stressing out because
because we're late and nina took a long
time
yeah right it took a long time to get
ready
stop blaming on me okay and it's raining
so now we have to go the other way
to go to walgreens to get an umbrella
for us so now we're gonna be even more
late
so the key in these situations is to
just drive really really fast in the
rain
here at epcot we're going in we got nina
and me and umbrella and hayden a special
poncho
and the real question is how is nina's
makeup gonna hold up
i usually put makeup when i go and i go
out but this morning i i did an extra
thick liner and a pull of fake false
lashes
i hope i don't get i don't get into the
ring too
too much otherwise uh the ring will soak
my
my my makeup and you will see all the
dark like
kinda bear hey it's not gonna be panda
favorite
painting
so i got the umbrella and we are now
standing in line at epcot
nina is wearing my hoodie because she
got cold oh look how cute she looked
hello and hayden has his poncho
and is who are you he's voldemort from
harry potter
but he looks like a ghost like a ghost
voldemort we're gonna get a stroller
today because we didn't want ours to get
wet it's supposed to rain all day long
so hopefully the rides will still be
open and hopefully
less people today last time we came here
this is coffee shop behind me that had
really bad coffee that i got last year
with louie
when he came and we were just
remembering that and then like you want
a coffee
maybe and she actually wants one of the
bad coffees again because
because otherwise have to wait for a
long time for a coffee so i'm gonna get
us some coffee
and we'll enjoy the bad coffee while
hayden plays
in the rain
okay the test track is closed because of
rain so we are gonna start our day
at mission space i initially thought
hayden this might be too
bumpy a ride for hayden but he loved the
roller coaster so much i think he's
ready for this mission
so i'm either going to be really right
he's going to love it
or i'm going to be really wrong and
we'll be in trouble all day you're going
to be an astronaut
you know space
that's what we're going to be flying on
look at that rocket huh
i can't move i'm gonna put the camera
down okay camera away come by we're
going to mars
to mars and back with commander hayden
did you have fun
that was a little scary huh
halfway through the ride hayden goes i'm
scared
but was it good are you glad we came
that's a big smile okay good
nina didn't press all the buttons
properly yeah right but but we still
made it through
i was scared for my life our pilot here
was it was very rocky that that ride
i did my job as engineering commander
hayden let us
okay let's keep going on our trip next
living with the land
we're gonna go on a boat ride my
sandwich is awesome
all right
this is a boring ride this is a boring
ride it's not
boring look at all the plants
it's boring it's educational
nina really wants to grow uh our own
garden at home and so
looking at all the different things that
they're growing here she's definitely
going to want to go home and
start growing some stuff it's spring
right you're going to want to
guarantee you look on the channel like a
month is going to be a we're setting up
our own garden
video
hayden is so excited right now look at
him it's crazy
he's so happy right now it's the best
ride ever
this is it this is the part nina's gonna
freak out over i know i know she's gonna
freak out
oh kale oh wow
okay next up we're gonna go see figment
what does figment say
oh hello hayden i love you so much is
that what pikmin says
yes parked the stroller it stopped
raining so we're happy
maybe the test track will open up we'll
see but now we gotta go see figment
oh
they're playing music with their hands
yeah this is a good look welcome to the
evan carmichael show
we're inside the frozen store and uh
hayden's going nuts about all this stuff
it's a dragon
we found a huge statue of nina in the
morning
thank you we're going into mexico
could we go up there yeah we're going to
go up in there here we go
we got here just in time opening up oh
who's this
hello
what's your name huh imagine meeting
you in a place like this
i'm mexican look at hayden
you're a mexican look can we get in
together well our heads are
yeah okay lunch time in mexico
we've got what is this nachos
chicken fingers with tortillas for
hayden and churros that's dessert with
caramel sauce after
yummy okay let's eat churros dessert
time
dip it in i need to dip it in oh
cheers okay try it how you doing
and it's cold it's cold that's good
we're going to china now here are the
gates
oh they wrote your name in chinese too
what does it say
nina it's not it but well this the last
one is done
but this one is more like sea done all
right
wait a minute which one is nina this is
what nina's makeup would look like if it
started to rain hard but so far so good
you don't have the big panda eyes yet
okay now we're in germany payne's
getting his germany stamp
let's see where is it cool it's a
germany mickey
we're in italy what did you get let's
see oh that's norway there's italy
all right we're in america now
okay now we're in japan cool look it's a
japanese flag with mickey mouse in the
middle okay now we're in morocco
get the stamp oh you got an eiffel tower
cool with the mickey on top
oh very scary tayden's getting his
england stamp
okay we are home in canada
native canadian stuff and that's the
castle in quebec
all right next up spaceship earth here
we are
english hello hayden hello nina
oh wow look at me there
what did you think yes we stopped
deposit starbucks because nina was
getting tired
so we're breaking for a little bit and
what's starbucks so we got
nina has a venti tiramisu
yeah try that out hayden gets a water
and an apple
it's a special wizard water
and evan gets wait all of the cups say
evan evan gets a caramel flan
frappuccino
cheers
okay we finished our frappuccinos and
drinks and
are we feeling more relaxed we have
energy
yeah okay oh there goes energy
so we are going to go to sauron
last year hayden was too small to go on
this and there's a
huge weight line typically so we did a
fast pass
and this is hayden's first time going on
it you can see here
115 minute standby wait time
i don't think i can film because we're
strapped in and we're going to be
lifted off the ground so it's a ton of
fun but we're gonna have to say goodbye
right here what did you think mister
i wanna go again you wanna go again that
looks very angry
was it fun yeah that's one of the best
things to see at disney time to go on
the finding nemo
ride the seas with nemo and friends
last main thing to do today is go see
the
characters and take pictures with them
who do you want to see today
all right we're leaving bye bye epcot
did you have fun today
yep what was your favorite part getting
this
getting that wow and a piece of paper
this and imagination the imagination
imagination is a blast whoa
so on our way home we decided to stop in
at one of the gift stores and buy
some disney swag so hayden got what did
you get
i got one of these special pencils
what what is the pen it's a pen what
does the pen do and if you push
any color down it does that color
but if you brush another color just a
tiny bit it goes up
and i got a book okay that you can draw
it
and and look at the pictures
and what did nina buy well i passed
somebody
some beer sauvignon souvenir souvenir
souvenir for
my nieces and nephew she loved like
princess frozen
sweater and then i also got her
a frozen wallet that's for my knees
and then for my nephew
i got a avengers t-shirt
he had a matching sandal so you can wear
that when he wear the sandals and then
i also got him some pencils
oh mickey and goofy and donald oh lots
of them they're all over they're
different
my little niece i got her
minnie now what did daddy buy
what did daddy buy daddy bought nothing
daddy just spent money
his daddy paid that he paid that's what
daddy bought daddy paid for your
happiness
are you guys happy yes good okay daddy's
gonna drive us home now
okay hayden did his first picture did
his first picture let's see
show us show us what you made what do
you want to show us
this is it what are we looking at here
what is this
it's a wizard a wizard okay
and and he has a magic hat
hold it up so we can see he has a magic
hat
he kills ghost he kills ghosts
with his magic what hand with his magic
hand okay
and hayden decided to watch some donald
duck
okay it's uh imagining it's eight
o'clock
so it's time for hayden to go to bed
it's imagination tomorrow we're going
back to
disney world no it's pigment disneyland
magic kingdom it's called disney world
we're going back to magic kingdom
tomorrow
to have more fun so that's it good night
and we'll see you tomorrow bye
self-improvement books are like fitness
books they never work on their own
what you need is a trainer that's evan
get the newsletter